hello and welcome to dry with the DW
motor magazine coming up natural gas on
the go Volkswagens new Polo TGI we're
off to Turkey for the sea to sky
endurance race and Mercedes posh new
pickup
with its new ex class mercedes is
breaking into a segment that German
carmaker has never tried before and a
bid to attract new customers to the
brand that's it yes the car tester says
it's the first of its kind until now
mercedes-benz had never built a pickup
truck that changes with the ex class its
brawny white enough for a shipping
pallet in the back and sturdy enough to
go off-road
this time we'll test-drive the
production version Mercedes already
showed off its ex class concept truck at
the Geneva Motor Show last spring its
aggressive design caught everyone's
attention with a huge grille slender
headlights and flared wheel wells
unfortunately the production version is
tame by comparison
2% plaintiff says what jumps out are the
Mercedes star in the radiator grille the
massive bumpers and the wide toe more
than 1.6 meters both front and rear this
not only gives the x-class of beefy
appearance it also helps to stabilize
the pickup on the highway off-road the
ex classes ground clearance of more than
20 centimeters helps it stay out of
trouble a centimeter a striking feature
is the ex classes grille the production
version has larger headlights than the
concept
in the rear the x-class boasts of
vertical taillights and a massive bumper
final says pickups have to be tough
whether they're going offroad or hauling
heavy loads the ex class can carry up to
1.1 tons on its bed and tow up to 3.5
tons the tailgate alone can withstand up
to 150 kilograms but despite all these
talents the two-ton truck drives almost
like a car the new ex class offers a
choice of two diesel engines we tested
the more powerful 140 kilowatt version
Mercedes rates fuel consumption at 7.8
liters for every 100 kilometers the
truck emits 207 grams of carbon dioxide
per kilometre and the top speed is 175
kilometers per hour
Pinal says the x-class is more
comfortable than its competitors a big
plus on longer journeys what's unusual
for Mercedes is the conventional
handbrake and automatic gear selector
lever mounted on the center tunnel
typical for Mercedes are the air vent
nozzles in the dashboard in fact the
x-class looks very refined for an SUV
what's more it seats five people
and as luxurious as its interior is the
pickup can handle rough terrain with
ease
I know says it's time to see what the ex
class can do off road to find out we
took it to a special test track the ice
class faces a tough climb and waged
through water up to sixty centimeters
deep a 25 degree descent and 30 degree
climb are sufficient for most
construction sites and the boat ramp at
the lake all variants of the pickup come
with rear-wheel drive and manual 6-speed
gearbox as standard switchable 4matic
four-wheel drive is available at a
surcharge for all engine types the
7-speed automatic is only available with
the current top model the ex 250 D which
we're testing
we're seeing these Christian pulses the
x-class is a real-life rotor and a real
pickup so 4matic is the perfect
all-wheel drive system for off-road use
for more challenging terrain it offers
gear reduction as well as a differential
lock and that really pulls it through
just about anywhere and there's more
power on the way for the ex class next
year Mercedes plans to roll out a
version powered by a 190 kilowatt 3
liter diesel v6
my note says the Mercedes x-class adds
new momentum to the pickup sector
technically the ex class is a close
relative of the Nissan Navara it's built
in the sameness on Factory in Barcelona
but the Navara is around 10000 euros
cheaper he says he wishes the ex class
would have looked like the concept truck
at the Geneva Motor Show
Auto Salon in Kent focused at hub but
even if the pickup could have been a bit
more daring in its design this latest
Mercedes model is still bound to turn
heads wherever it goes
the challenge the entire automotive
industry is facing now is how to cut
emissions but there are many ways to do
that diesel has fallen out of favor and
electric power faces many hurdles but
other alternatives are often overlooked
for testing mono well is well aware of
how controversial diesel is but what's
the alternative the German government is
pushing electric in hybrid drives but
they're costly to make and to buy so for
now Volkswagen is developing cars that
run on CNG or compressed natural gas
specifically natural gas is almost all
methane when burned in an engine it
releases about 25 percent less co2 than
gasoline does and less particulate
matter and nitrogen oxide so VW will be
offering a CNG version in each of its
range lines
yes Anderson of Volkswagen flatly
rejects the notion that the auto
industry will be able to go all-electric
with batteries in the near future
he insists that's physically impossible
even if there are many transportation
needs that can be adequately met by
battering electric vehicles and CNG
should not be seen as a competitor to
electric drive but rather as a
compliment he agrees that long chain and
cyclic hydrocarbons must be phased out
but says more can be done with
conventional drive trains and here
methane is especially attractive mere
tool but in convincing an aunt even once
the treatment metal besonders are teeth
the newest member of ewc and chief
family is the pulao TGI it's powered by
a three cylinder bivalent engine meaning
it can use two kinds of fuel in addition
to the gasoline tank
it carries to natural gas tanks under
the floor of the trunk running on
natural gas
the pulao consumes 3.2 kilograms per 100
kilometers and emits just 87 grams of
co2 per kilometer
so nice that's my Anderson explains that
Volkswagen has specially designed the
engines to run on natural gas so they
don't have to be converted after the
fact once questions come be done all the
engines operation has to be dry and
smooth so VW has redesigned the cylinder
heads it's something the company is able
to add across its engine range does ask
my VCR based on Toyota for methane can
not only be extracted from non-renewable
sources but also from renewable
alternatives in biogas plants for
example this is another important factor
in preserving the environment
the Moonville points out that natural
gas cars cost much less than electric
are even hybrid cars he takes the Polo
as an example the natural gas version
started just under 20,000 euros in
Germany for the CNG models worth the
additional 7,000 euros over the purely
gasoline powered models maybe not in the
short run but longer-term a lower fuel
consumption not only saves money at the
pump but helps preserve the environment
by cutting down on co2 emissions
Henderson emphasizes that this is not
just a stopgap solution he says in the
long term we'll have to learn to deal
with natural gas power alongside battery
electric power and judging by the
current state of technology we'll also
have to deal with fuel cell powered
vehicles so it would be a good idea to
learn to handle natural gas energy
sources darlin but Gosselin indicates
Regan
therefore tagging you manual adds that
the advantage over an electric vehicle
is that you can simply drive to the
filling station fill the tank in less
than 10 minutes and drive on but once an
electric vehicles battery is empty you
have to plug it in and then you can't
drive anywhere until it's recharged but
what does it feel like to drive a pole
OTG I the natural gas pool low is too
loud for Romano's taste the engine
doesn't run smoothly but he says that
has less to do with the natural gas and
more to do with the three cylinders in
this otherwise it's hard to see or feel
any difference between gasoline and CNG
Drive
so using natural gas doesn't mean giving
up any of the fun of driving aside from
the lower purchase price another plus
for the natural gas polo / electric
drive is that range is no concern
dad man well once again reminds us of
the advantage of the natural gas portal
using both CNG and gasoline once the
natural gas tank is empty you can keep
going on gasoline until you reach the
next natural gas filling station
Porsche has unveiled the GTS version of
its 7:18 Cayman
well it's 2.5 liter four-cylinder boxer
engine and an optimized turbocharger
that GTS now delivers 269 kilowatts of
power 12 more than the Cayman S the
Cayman GTS shoots from 0 to 100 km/h and
4.6 seconds prices for the Cayman GTS
start at 76 thousand euros in Germany
Lamborghini has launched its first SUV
the Eurus offers luxury and superlative
performance it reaches 100 km/h in just
3.6 seconds and has a top speed of 305
km/h making it the fastest SUV on the
market and as you would expect for a
Lamborghini its angular design exudes
sportiness all of this comes at a price
the Lamborghini heiress will be
available in Europe next spring starting
at 171 thousand euros
Timur is a popular Turkish seaside
resort and one weekend a year
it's the venue for the sea the sky
extreme enduro motorcycle race this year
marks the eighth edition of the
three-day event 180 riders from 23
countries are taking part the main race
starts on the beach before heading into
the forest and up olympus mountain to
the finish
I had a real good day I managed to be in
front of most of the day I'm just
keeping a good flood of having fun there
are 11 checkpoints along the 65
kilometer long route steep cliffs and
stony sections make the course a real
challenge see the sky is regarded as one
of the hardest extreme enduro races with
it's constantly changing conditions a
three day race pushes many riders to
their limits both physically and
mentally
my day was perfect from the beginning I
had a decent start more than life 4/5
then I ever passed the riders yes after
the super enduro and after that I ride
my own race I've been living like one
hour or something like that it was
really close following sea the sky is so
demanding that of the 180 writers who
started the race just 47 reached the
finish line the other's bodies her bikes
simply gave out world-class riders like
Mario Roman Wade young Graham Jarvis and
Johnny Walker thrilled the crowds and
gave it their all to secure a place on
the podium
Wade young has competed here several
times before this year he finished third
happy to be on the podium I could have
been on any one of the three boxes today
we're all right good together gram and
Mario we've pretty much wrote together
most of the day I was trying to save my
energy a [ __ ] for that last year and
grams just and animals so to try keep up
with them and they also tied myself out
a bit more but you know what I'm on the
podium I've had a bit of bad luck the
last races so to finish and be on the
podium I'm stoked more deluxe been first
but I gave it everything today so I'll
take third I'm happy with that
Spaniard Mario Roman was the second
rider to reach the finish line
I'm really happy with the second place
Congrats to Bahamas Congrats to wait for
the core unit really happy with the team
and for sake of factory team thanks
everyone
English but Graham Jarvis took the
checkered flag the 42 year olds many
years of experience gave him the edge
I just can't believe it one because as
you know I was behind for so long and
then I was just thinking how this could
42 years old just give me the last
chance so I just have to keep going and
pushing as hard as I can I'm gonna break
the front brake and have to fix it a
little bit but you know towards the end
I don't know what happened I just I just
went through and that little extra
effort paid off big in the end
dead to us on today runny lipstick is
testing it to son Hyundai has produced a
compact SUV since 2005 a Korean model
with an American name like Tucson
Arizona that's built in the Czech
Republic and designed by a German that's
true globalization Hyundai named the
second generation of this crossover
model the ix35 and many markets but the
current third generation is known as the
Tucson pretty much everywhere the SUV
hits the streets with a striking new
design and more self-confidence and it's
great fun to drive we're testing the
version with the style equipment package
Bernie says the Tucson snow
featherweight depending on the engine
and trim level it can weigh up to 1.7
tons but then Hyundai wasn't aiming to
build a lightweight vehicle but rather a
robust compact SUV that's also good on
long hauls
he thinks the Tucson does that quite
well
at the front the crossovers striking
design can't be overlooked the large
hexagonal radiator grille that's typical
for Hyundai models and the new LED
headlights are both real attention
getters
from the side the two Sun also cuts a
good figure the gradually rising window
line and the black cladding over the
wheel wells at a touch of sportiness
at the rear the most eye-catching
feature is the horizontal taillights but
the twin tailpipes also add to the
overall impression
compared to the second generation the
new Tucson Bo's 10% more cargo space it
can hold 513 liters or around 1500
liters with the rear seats folded down
so there's plenty of room among the two
sons driver assists are an automatic
emergency braking system which combines
radar and camera data to detect that the
car ahead makes a sudden stop the two
top trim line style and premium both
come equipped with a rear view camera as
well as the smart Park Assist the style
version also features a lane departure
warning system Feli Fermi says there are
many adjustments that can be made in the
Tucson you can lock the center
differential because we have all-wheel
drive and there's a button to adjust the
steering there are two modes sports and
normal Ronnie doesn't think there's much
difference between the two though
steering might be a bit stiffer in sport
mode relized mini Maya Stratus lightning
sport models
black dominates the car's interior the
center console is well laid out and
pepped up a little by the piano black
details the infotainment system is
clearly arranged and easy to use thanks
to its touchscreen and buttons the
leather steering wheel feels good in
your hands and has just a few buttons to
control the radio and the dashboard
display and though the seats aren't
leather they're two-tone fabric looks
sharp the Tucson comes with a choice of
eight engines five diesel and three
gasoline-powered our test model is
fitted with a 136 kilowatt diesel engine
the most powerful one on offer it
propels the Tucson from 0 to 100 km/h
and around 10 seconds the top speed is
202 km/h and fuel consumption is
surprisingly low for an SUV of this size
just 6.5 liters per 100 kilometers
mommy says with the two son Hyundai was
one of the first car makers to introduce
a compact SUV the segment so promptly
that other automakers have followed suit
so the competition keeps growing but he
thinks the Hyundai Tucson will stay a
contender in this segment for a while to
come
20:17 was the first year Germany's retro
classic vintage car fare took place in
Cologne previously it had only been held
in stood got now one of the world's
largest vintage car fairs is branching
out to Cologne and Nuremberg it brings
together fans collectors and their
darlings from every continent among them
is Walter Klein with his Ford Taunus the
minister he explains the cars attraction
for him when he was a teenager a friend
had the same kind of car and he worked
on it a lot because his friend wasn't
mechanically inclined vintage and
classic car buffs have plenty to feast
their eyes on at the Cologne retro
classics from historic tractors to
high-powered Ferraris and Porsches to
veteran formula 1 racers Wolfgang
Chernabog is here showing off his Ford
gt40 a milestone in Fords history
to him the attraction is the excitement
of sitting in and driving a car with a
racing history behind it but it all
started with a card game when he was a
boy one of the cards had a gt40 on it
and he told himself he had to have a car
like that someday
imitate utter and super Tony Lamas who
do not have dual automatic Omaha
Ford took advantage of the fair to
exhibit some of the highlights of its 85
year company history 12 models from the
American automakers classic car
collection spanned the decades for the
1930s Model A - the newest version of
the Ford Fiesta Ford's Wolfgang loafer
says the beginning of production in
Cologne in 1931 with this car the Model
A was a major milestone for the company
more recent models attract their share
of interest -
Ford enthusiasts Stefan bucket is here
with his Ford Escort explains that part
of the vintage Ford's attraction is that
they're so easy to work on spare parts
are relatively easy to find in terms of
market share the escort has a status and
Britain much like the VW Beetle had in
Germany so all kinds of parts are still
made and owners have little problem
fixing them on their own Ford has been
producing cars in cologne for more than
85 years now a lot has changed in that
time currently more than 25,000 people
from over 100 countries worked for Ford
Germany
carsten vana and Klaus Nita Bagga have
been with the Ford classic department
for seven years from Annapolis neither
burgers started with four - 1985 when
they urgently needed automotive
electricians he previously worked for
Bosch for 14 years
at first coming from a family business
he felt like he was only a number but
workers can build careers at Ford -
Clemence Thomas Carson van de adds that
he and the others learned all about
these engines but the old carburetors
and distributors aren't made anymore so
today's younger mechanics don't know how
to deal with them but when he works on
vintage cars his experience stands him
in good steed and he has fun with this
profession also on display or some
affords other brands like luxury brand
Lincoln the O ice explains that Lincoln
was the first outside company Ford
acquired it's still a part of for today
and the cars are still sold in the
United States
he thinks Lincoln's are grand
collectors items and rarities may be
driven carefully or simply pampered and
polished to keep them in mint condition
these treasures are carried in on
trailers
well hon Osmo Vettes confirms that he
only transports his cars on trailers to
vintage car meets and events he might
drive them on racetracks but otherwise
he just keeps them in the garage under
wraps
now the vintage and classic car fans
have put their darlings back to bed to
sleep peacefully until next year's retro
classics in Cologne next time on drive
it sporty on the outside roomy on the
inside that's the new VW Golf sportsvan
and exotic but practical we test the
Subaru levorg wagon